la pandémie n'apport ralenti leurs
ardeurs entre 2016 et 2021 le Canada a
accueilli un nombre record des migrants
ils sont 1,3 millions en majorité
originaire de l'Inde des Philippines et
de la Chine avoir choisi le Canada
l'Ontario demeure la terre d'accueil la
plus prisée 44% des nouveaux arrivants
ont décidé de s'y établir entre 2016 et
2021 une augmentation de 4%. à l'inverse
le Québec qui arrive deuxième a été le
choix de 15% d'entre eux une baisse de
2,5%. et une nouvelle tendance se
dessine ils sont de moins en moins
nombreux à choisir des grands centres on
a une communauté nord-africaine Caroline
hargan et directrice du Centre d'emploi
de la région de Prescott Russell dans
l'estontarien elle observe cette
tendance qui fait la joie des
entreprises de la région qui comme
ailleurs manquent de travail ailleurs ça
m'encourage énormément de voir que les
immigrants oui choisissent des milieux
ruraux dans la région
peut-être une cinquantaine soixantaine
d'individus en tout et partout là si on
se rapproche de plus près d'Ottawa et le
plus grand défi selon elle ce n'est pas
de séduire les immigrants le plus grand
frère c'est le processus
d'immigration le ministre de
l'Immigration reconnaît qu'il y a du
travail à faire
plus que seulement en parler
d'illuministre sans préciser comment
même scénario au Québec la seule
province qui a le pouvoir de
sélectionner les travailleurs qualifiés
désirant et immigrés le Premier ministre
le goût est à la recherche d'une
stratégie on va le regarder d'une façon
nouvelle avec des suggestions tout le
monde une nouvelle ministre Christine
Frechette qui est ouverte au suggestions
mais ce que j'ai dit c'est que c'est non
négociable faut arrêter déclin du
français au Québec 70% des nouveaux
arrivants n'ont ni le français ni
l'anglais comme langue maternelle quand
vient le temps de choisir l'une des deux
langues officielles les données
démontrent qu'à l'extérieur du Québec 9
immigrants sur dix ne parlent anglais
alors qu'au Québec plus de la moitié
d'entre eux par uniquement le français
et si Valérie Gamache au Canada